Se arambió, no se que le llamabas, entonces toda la gente sobró de esas zonas se vinieron aquí.
Leí en el libro de Don Carlitos López, dice de que hay eso de que el general Federico Román trae gente.
Era en 1930, me olvide ese detalle, trajo gente de baure y de San Joaquín, como dice usted.
Pero llegaron en mayor cantidad de cachuelas de San Joaquín por esos problemas que tuvieron.
Sí, porque ahorita que un tecita, mi abuela llegó de cachuelas, se vino acá con mi mamá y mi tío en 1940.
Me daba bajando la fama de cachuelas, no tiene alguna foto de cachuelas, no voy, no de cachuelas, no, le voy a preguntar a mi mamá.
Me cacha de la vez.
Ay, ya no hay la cacha, sería natural.
Entonces eso es verdad. Me cuenta todo ese no, porque claro, muere Don Nicolás, que era el papá digamos, y ya la gente empieza a emigrar pues no.
Ya que sí, entonces por esa razón se funda.
Y bueno, ya organizado, ya justamente en 1992, cuando estaba en el gobierno, ahí me pasa Mora,
se lo declara a Guayaramerín Ciudad.
-Efue el 92, ¿no? -El 92, Ciudad.
Ya se estaba más ensanchando Ciudad, le dan el título Ciudad.
En 1994 a Guayaramerín le dan 10 kilómetros de redonda para su urbanización, hay una ley también que le da la ley.
En 1995 a Guayaramerín, en vez de Villabella, porque Villabella era capital de la segunda sección,
ahora como no había nadie allá, entonces Guayaramerín pasó a ser capital de la segunda sección de la provincia de Ciudad, ¿no?
-¿Cuánta Villabella se vació? -No, pues un billorio ahorita, un mar y vino.
En todo lo que era Villabella, Tepela, quedaron en Granada, imagínate Villabella, yo conocí la catedral en Miguel.
-Yo voy a ir a conocerlo. -Tabía conocí la última calle, la avenida principal a Doquinada, en todo eso que ven en Mono.
Pero hay un obelisco que lo construyeron en 1925, cuando Bolíe cogió 100 años, ¿sabes?
-Yo lo propuse el obelisco para Guayaramerín para este año, pero el alcalde no acuerda. -No hay presupuesto.
Como siempre. Entonces, esa es la historia de Guayaramerín.
-Ahora pasando a la creación, ¿de cómo surge ese del Guaya... -Ah, bueno, con todas esas leyes, los historiadores,
entre medio estaba el profesor de Gerson Fernández, el profesor Osvaldo Cabral y otros, Don Carlos López,
entre medio mi persona, la profesora Gabi Cuellar, se queríamos un algo que nos identifique.
Es así de que Milton Castro lo actualiza el Tres Araúl, que lo baila en todos los años aquí en Guayaramerín.
Es el mismo Saraúl, pero ha estilizado lo que don Milton Castro.
El Tipói lo crea doñadora, vives de Castro, pero era blanco, así con cruzado, el Tipói blanco para Guayaramerín,
ese es el Guayaripoi. -¿Doña Dora? -Doña Dora Vides de Castro. -¿Liura? -Vides. -Ah, Vides.
Vives de Castro, profesora. -Vives de Castro. ¿Y él, este, vive o ya? -No, ella es muestra.
Lo actualiza el Guayaripoi, es Gerson Fernández, con ya los colores de la bandera, de la bandera de Guayaramerín.
-Hace cruz, es Gerson. -Sí. Él lo actualiza el Guayaripoi. -Lo que conocemos como ahora, ya con la bandera, ¿no?
Después, el Ignon a la Guayaramerín, eso fue más antes, el profesor Reinaldo lo ahí sacaron.
-Ese profesor Arto ha cortado a Guayaram, ¿no? -Reinaldo lo ahí sacaron. -Sí.
Después, el escudo, fue Don Juan Mendoza, el escudo de Juan Mendoza.
-Pero ese fue un concurso? -Concursos. -No, Juan Mendoza, y su esposa, ¿no?
No, el oficial Vertís Blanco, Vertís Blanco, un oficial de la bandera, entre la bandera y el escudo.
-El escudo. -Eso fue el escudo. La bandera, la bandera no recuerdo esta, por ahí sí.
-Juan Mendoza dijo el escudo? -El escudo, el pintor.
-Ah, era pintores y un militar. -Y un militar, de apellido Vertís Blanco, su nombre no me acuerdo.
Vertís Blanco, y qué profesor.
Y el profesor Gerson Fernández, debió escribir también, en el palacio, debe haber, no, voy a ir por el palacio.
-Ah, ya, ya, ya, pero... -Y aquí hay la biografía de Reinaldo loal,